I want to say thank you to the the
jurors for being willing to make that
that tough decision I want to say thank
you to the prosecutors for the for the
excellent job that they did and now
we're just going to move forward and
continue to respond in the appropriate
way going forward but we just want to
say and the other thing that I want to
say is that this also lets us know that
the God that we serve is still on the
front God is still in control all along
I have some other of my associates with
me Jonathan Morrison and I also caught
in packer I'd like for them to have kept
coming we're gonna do it this time we're
gonna take a few questions and when I
take the family back we believe in the
wisdom of this jury that that decision
is in the hands of this jury and so I'm
we believe that both um's life mattered
and we want to see a sentence that
reflects that and many people a lot of
commentators said there would be no
murder conviction right so right now
we're already ahead of the game and we
welcome the jury's decision as a
attorney merit and attorney Washington
have said what we do know though is that
Amber Geiger got to understand and she
testified without a doubt that she
intended to kill both them and we just
hope that the jury remembers that this
is an individual that say she didn't
make a mistake she intended to kill and
we think that the sentence that they
give her she lived [ __ ] reflect you
don't know what imagine what the
sentence would be if the roles were
reversed and both of John kill amber
Geiger why can't it be equal justice in
America no matter what the ethnicity of
the murderer is and two days two days
after she killed both him she was back
sexting and talking about getting drunk
so this is a person that has no remorse
this is a person being in jail for five
to six years will not be enough so we
want the census to definitely reflect
that do you worry
well here's what we know and I let leach
out but here's what we know we didn't I
think a mistake of fact and the castle
doctrine should have gotten in there but
with the family know today and what we
feel comfortable about there's really
nothing that the defense gonna be able
to appeal they got everything that they
wanted so and then they did not get the
verdict that they wanted so we feel good
about that and I'll just reiterate that
the mistake effect in particularly the
castle doctrine was asinine to go before
this jury they had no business up
asserting the castle doctrine in someone
else's home I'm glad that the jury
simply rejected that and we can move
forward from there say when you think
about the Casa doctrine it really
reminds you a lot of stand your ground
when you come up with an intellectual
justification to justify the killing of
an unarmed black person thank god the
jury did not accept it if you sit if you
said number one and I said if we were
calling the game if we were calling this
like a game the score was ninety two to
zero the entire time the the the only
concern was that the jury instructions
it bothered me that those will go back
and in the end in that case you could
have run away but but when it's all said
and done you had someone who was
completely unarmed completely nonviolent
completely non aggressive sitting at his
home eating a bowl of ice cream and
someone barged into his home and shot
him to death and so when this family
contacted us the day after this murder
we we believe that the right the right
conviction would happen we believe that
the right verdict will come out as
guilty we knew that in America that's
rare we knew we had a fight on our hands
but they were all the pieces in place
and I'll tell you what this was a
perfect storm of events in terms of the
justice system working together you had
a motivated District Attorney's Office
who put on an excellent case you had a
progressive dish a progressive judge who
made the right calls from the bench and
you had a Dallas County community that
responded to the call to serve on these
juries as we need them to continue to do
so you had one of the most diverse
juries that we ever seen and when all
those things work together I was I was
convicted I was certain of a conviction
in this case this Dallas County has a
precedence and I like anybody else in
America remember Jordan Ellis case right
a district attorney faith Johnson made
sure that that young unarmed child's
life was not in vain when they got a
conviction there and now to get a
conviction here hopefully all the rest
of the cities all across the United
States will learn from Dallas Texas that
justice means equal justice and one
final thing one final thing that we when
we said it before were Mike Rivera there
by deleting those text messages that is
something that just cannot go away
that's right because that was clear
tampering with evidence and that's going
to be something that we're gonna follow
up on and we're gonna make sure that the
Dallas Police Department is following
the proper procedures because as a
result of not following up on people
like Mike Rivera there's a mother that
we talked to who might Rivera took her
took her son's life that's still dealing
with that from 2007 so we need to make
sure that that's followed up on what
what this what this trial did was it put
the veil back and we saw the kind of
things that lead to unfair acquittal of
police officers we saw a corrupt Dallas
Police Department that actively engaged
in covering for excusing and justifying
the unjustifiable and now that that veil
has been pulled back we are we've all
seen it and we we have an obligation on
behalf of this family we have a us in
this community has an obligation to go
after the bad actors who try to cover
this murder up from the beginning that's
including her part in Martin Rivera
that's including Mike Mata of the Dallas
Police Officers Association we call on
chief Hall to clean house because we're
going to go about the business of
cleaning house for